all right hello everyone uh welcome back
from uh all of the the great breakout
sessions that were going on throughout
the day
um i hope that everyone had a lot of fun
and those breakouts
getting to meet with with the the team
that nominated
you and and some of those researchers
but hopefully also being able to kind of
jump around to some of the other
research groups
and get a sense for all of the great uh
ai research going on
at msr right now across the org um
so this is is our final session for for
the ai breakthroughs event
um we're gonna wrap things up with with
a final session
of talks some really interesting um
technical talks
from from three researchers here at msr
and then so we're going to have three
talks kind of similar to what we did
yesterday
we'll have all three talks in a row and
then we'll bring all the speakers
together
for a panel style q a um but just like
yesterday i encourage you all to
type your questions into the chat um
throughout the talks
um or after the the talks are over
um and and we will we will try to answer
some in the chat like throughout the
talks
but then we'll get to to all the rest of
them uh in the q a
after that so i'm going to kick things
off first of all
uh with our first speaker um so it's my
pleasure to introduce chomsky iqbal
from the information and data sciences
group at microsoft research
uh shamsi has done a lot of great work
focused on work and on multitasking and
attention
and and ways to support sort of um
good work practices in the modern work
landscape
um and so today we're going to hear a
talk um on micro productivity
so take it away chomsky
hello everyone and thank you for joining
this session i am champs iqbal
a researcher in the information and data
sciences group in microsoft research
in this talk i will be talking about how
productivity research
is changing as our landscape of work is
changing
and how some of our ongoing work fits
into this changing
new future of work please go ahead and
add your questions to the hub channel
after this recording i'll be here to
answer any questions that you might have
so i wanted to start off by
acknowledging the amazing
team that i had privilege of working
with over the past few years
with any great work in the background
there are tons of people working
together
collaborating and that's how you come up
with
research that can actually impact a lot
of people
so the bottom two rows i want to call
out especially because these are
our amazing interns who come and work
with us every summer
and help us produce some of the research
that i will be describing today
so i wanted to start off with some
motivation behind this work
the traditional way of being productive
is setting aside time to focus
and get work done however the fact of
the matter
is that user attention is fragmented and
part of this fragmentation comes from
the fact
that human beings are natural
multitaskers some of you might be
listening to this talk and also maybe
answering emails or doing something else
on the side
and we are able to do that we want to
and tend to do multiple things at the
same time
but often we also overestimate our
ability to multitask efficiently
contrary to what what we might believe
for ourselves
we face challenges in protecting our
attention
from both external and internal
interruptions
and also in directing attention to the
right thing at the right moment
so while we don't want something like
this
if we think about it micro moments exist
in
many times during the day take for
example
you're waiting for a talk to start you
are waiting in line to get
coffee or your food you are waiting for
the elevator to show up so there are
these little bits and pieces of moments
that if you put them together it becomes
a substantial chunk of time
and i would also like to introduce you
to the new normal which is our current
reality
most people especially information
workers and students
are now currently working from home or
attending classes from home
and this presents some unique challenges
that productivity researchers did not
have to think about before
now we are either coexisting with a lot
of other people who each have have
different goals
and they may not share your own goals
and your need for productivity at the
same time
or their their goals are not aligned
there are also other people who are
living alone
they're missing the opportunity to work
with their collaborators
to be together to brainstorm
and that has a mental tax
and it makes it just more difficult for
people to focus on one single
thing they either interrupt themselves
or they get
keep getting interrupted so they have to
switch and back and forth between the
tasks they're trying to focus on
and other tasks they're demanding their
attention
so i wanted to start off with talking
about new ways of
getting work done what is ironic is that
the research that i'm going to talk
about
is not necessarily new we have been
looking at this for
quite a number of years but in the
current situation it seems to be
quite applicable so
i want to introduce the notion of
microtask some of you may already know
about these
but basically the idea of microtasks
have their root in psychology literature
and the definition that i like to use
most
is the research of newton and inquest
microtests are essentially perceptual
units of behavior
there are chunks of a larger task that
combined together to achieve a broader
goal
and micro productivity is the
transformation
of these bigger goals or productivity
related tasks
into smaller manageable chunks that you
can
do in a few seconds few minutes or
something that can be done in a
reasonable amount of time
so if you decompose a larger task into
its component microtask
then we can start mapping these
microtasks into the various
micro moments that exist throughout the
day so now
instead of having to set aside a long
period of time to do
a larger task you can essentially pick
out those smaller micro tests that can
be done independently
and try to do them some of them in your
micro moments so that's kind of like the
general idea around micro productivity
so i wanted to quickly emphasize
especially in the context of working
from home and interleaving multitasking
has some distinct
benefits in terms of task switching
needs
which we increasingly find happening as
we work from home
or work in attentionally challenging
scenarios so multitasking is happening
when attention is switched between
multiple things of interest uh
what happens with microtask is because
these things are so small that you are
also doing rapid task switching
so if a micro test gets interrupted it's
so small that you can actually finish it
before you move on to the next thing so
in some sense microtasks are probably
more resilient to the negative effects
of
multitasking that we all uh talk about
so let's talk a little bit about
microtasking in today's world because
you may already realize that we are
already doing some of these
so when we think about microtasking or
we think about okay
we're on the go we have a few seconds
what can we do
we check email we maybe do some
communication we chat
we can check things off our to-do list
or we can do some quick browsing
what we typically don't do is that we
don't think about
writing an entire paper using micro
moments or creating a presentation using
micro moments
and god forbid coding absolutely out of
question
so essentially we feel that comp the
complex
tasks are not compatible with micro
moments
so i wanted to quickly um highlight two
micro tasks so
i think that all of us are probably well
aware of crowd workers and they tend to
have these smaller things that they can
do and they can do many of them
uh these are tasks that are that can be
completed without
requiring um much context and then
there's also automation so you could
imagine that you could identify
parts of a test that can be
automatically completed a very naive
example is uh that you could
automatically
identify a sentence that needs some
correction and the system could
correct it for you without having to
invoke the user
and then there's also of course
self-sourcing you decide that this is a
micro test that you need to do
you don't want to do it right now so you
you self-source it for yourself and so
you can find
a small chunk of time where you can
actually go and address that micro task
so in terms of sourcing your own task
what can be sourced or what are suitable
microtests
so i would like to emphasize here is
that we are not proposing that
everything can be microcast they can't
but
there are some parts of your broader
test spectrum that can be actually
microtest
and these are typically that tasks that
can be done rapidly without requiring
much context
so an example could be is that you're
writing a paper you need to find a
citation
but you're also in flow so you don't
want to break that flow and go
and and to your citation manager and
drag it out but you can do that
task later if it is uh presented to you
when you have a few minutes at your hand
and the other other things that can be
microcast are tested for which
information is not immediately available
so that they need to be different
and so the next question is that well
how do we do it
so many of us might be already doing
this manually
um you could imagine that well here's a
timeline of a day and then you are
sometimes you're on your computer
sometimes you have your mobile device
you have to take into account uh what
screen real estate you have available so
if you have a laptop you can do a bit
more if you only have a mobile device so
you're not only
challenged in terms of your available
cycles
attentional cycles but you're also
challenged in terms of the space that's
available
so the task needs to fit into not only
the micro moments but also the device
that you have
access to so
for the next few slides i'm going to do
a whirlwind
uh tour of the microproductivity
research that has happened at microsoft
over the past few years
and um i have links to most of the
papers that we have published and i'll
be happy to answer
uh some of the questions or that you
might have at the end of this uh
this session so we started off
looking at two main domains we started
off actually looking at
writing because we felt that this was a
complex enough domain
that had a few things that could be
micro tests and we wanted to use that as
our example domain and part of the
reason why we picked this is that again
as i said at the beginning
we don't typically think of writing or
content creation as something that can
be done in small chunks of time
we usually want to set aside focused
time to do these kinds of things
so this is just an overview of kind of
like what we wanted to do we wanted to
understand the domain
we wanted to understand how we can
create content from scratch
we wanted to see how we can actually
edit a content and
how can we create workflows and this
also led us into
understanding how we could apply the
same principles in a different domain
so talking more about generalizability
so we started off with
looking at well i mean if we create
content from scratch and mostly via
microtest can we do it and so we took
kind of like uh michael bernstein's find
fix verify
model and we modified a little bit and
so we broke it into we want to collect
content
we want to organize the content and then
we want to expand the content into
writing and
the first two steps or well actually in
this case all three steps can be done on
your mobile device using micro moments
you generate a bunch of ideas you then
group the ideas into uh into a group of
themes
and then for each theme you write up one
or two sentences this could be done
in a few seconds on your mobile device
or on your laptop computer
and then there's a final stage which is
basically integrating all the outcomes
and that is something that you
can't do via microtest that has to be
done um ideally on a desktop computer
with a little more than
just micro moments uh there was also a
similar thread
can you actually use uh what to
write a paper and so in this case it was
uh writing a paper bringing together a
bunch of people who can actually create
the content
but the the coordination of creating the
content was happening through a watch
so if you're the main author and you
have a bunch of crowd workers you create
all these instructions for them and they
start putting the content so their task
is not microtest
but as the coordinator as the author all
of your coordination is happening just
using micro moments
so um i wanted to move on to using micro
tasks for editing and this is where
you can imagine that you have already
con content that exists and you want to
do some editing tests so it's almost
that you have done the first part of
content creation and so you you have
some tasks that you already knew
know that you want to do on your own on
your content and so we
we created created this tool called
playwright
and it basically uh helps you edit
existing content on a mobile device
uh via microtasks and so what it does is
that there's a framework that would
analyze you
analyze your word document identify
microtasks upload it to a server
and then you could see these um
microtask on your mobile phone in a kind
of like a game-like format and so the
idea was that
we don't want to make everything feel
like work so these are things that you
can do in a few seconds
and they're completed in a mobile app in
a game-like fashion and so
i don't know whether you can see this
very well but these are you can see that
you're only seeing a little bit of text
and it's
asking a person to collect or correct
the spelling or fix
the the grammatical mistakes or decide
whether they want to accept or reject
the change and whatnot
so we also wanted to see what happens
and well when you are creating
content or editing content via microtest
like this is that well what is the
quality of the document
and so uh we are presenting a paper in a
mobile api this year that actually looks
at that experiences that well
um when are people so how are people
creating these micro tasks and what are
the typically the type of microtest that
people create when they're
writing something so that they can
remain in flow when are they completing
these microtasks
and then what is the quality of the
document when you get back and so what
we find is that in comparison to a
mobile task editing tool like mobile
board
when you present the content to people
via microtask it's very focused people
are able to
in most cases they're able to do these
tasks very quickly and keep
engaged and the other thing is that they
most cases they don't really need the
whole document and people are picking
out micro tests that they can actually
do
in small micro moments people did them
on buses people did them
during their uh during their short
breaks before meetings and whatnot
so they are picking tasks that they know
that they can do in short time and in
short attention spans uh we also
uh have uh another way that we can in
include microtests in in other
environments so for example we did
an experiment where we included micro
tasks in
uh as people were browsing facebook and
we wanted to see how it
interplayed with people's need to go and
take a break and what happens if they
see microtest
and this was a lightweight way of
engaging activities that are
backgrounded
we found that people could ignore these
microtests as just as they would ignore
any other kind of
non-facebook task but after a while they
felt good about
engaging with some of them because it
felt it made them feel that they were
actually
completing tasks without getting super
engaged with them
uh we also did some research looking at
how we can incorporate the crowd in our
work and so in this research we looked
at if we present
the crowd with a snippet of a text can
they
go through each line and quickly provide
some kind of ranking on whether this is
free of spelling and grammatical errors
or you could provide any any other kind
of question there
and when the feedback goes back to the
author they see an
average uh color-coded uh text that can
kind of like give them a sense of the
quality of the text that they can and
this is most
most from mostly from a copy editing
point of view and so this is how you can
incorporate the crowd so that they can
quickly give people feedback
without having to know too much about
the document itself
we also looked at intelligent support
during writing and so
if you want to include nlp for example
uh to help out people with writing and
so we wanted to compare this with in
incorporating the crowd or the author
themselves and what we found is that
when nlp revisions are typically small
they were typically improvements and
when you have nlp
then crowd uh the major idea of nlp
changes the crowd lead them
leave them unchanged but uh what we
found is
that the authors they tend to prefer
their own edits
versus when you give it to an
independent evaluator they tend to
prefer more of the nlp plus crowd kind
of edit so so there's
some benefit in incorporating
intelligent support
but authors do have some kind of like
bias towards their own writing obviously
there's also design for intelligence
work that we published in kai
2019 and this is a very interesting
piece of work where we looked at early
user experience designed for intelligent
experiences while writing
and traditionally design includes
storyboarding
and uh and wireframes but when you're
designing for intelligent experiences
none of those actually work because it
depends
on on the contents the underlying data
and so we we had some interesting ideas
around how we could totally frame this
as a different problem
and incorporate ways that we could
actually test it
without having to have the full model in
the background
so because of time i'm going to quickly
go over this so there was some work that
we looked at how we can help people ramp
up into work
writing and ram down from writing
building context and transition and help
people
do multiple micro tasks on the same
content so that they build the context
and that helps them easily ramp up into
working
into writing uh we wanted to see how we
can help the
crowd help build context for the crowd
so that the communication between the
crowd member
and the author is reduced but the crowd
can get the answers to the questions
that they might have uh ahead of time so
that they they can actually create the
content for the for the author
and finally the big question is that how
can you create these workflows or create
these micro tests
uh this is work that we did with hermann
cover uh in in
2017 i believe and so this was a really
nice piece of work where we started off
with creating a set of limited
vocabulary and these vocabularies were
then used to create plans
and so there were a fixed number of
steps and then depending on the type of
the
task that the step included it could be
done by the author it could be done by
someone else or it could be automated
um quickly we we had looked at how we
can use microtest for ramping up and
ramping down at work and so you could
answer
a few questions about your plan for the
day and the how you want to feel about
the day that helps you easily ramp up to
work
and at the end of the day to help you
disengage from work answer a few
questions about their reflection about
the day
and we uh wanted to see how that that
kind of like impacted people's
productivity and it turns out that
having that exercise at the beginning
and at the end of the day
help people have a more sustained
productive day
we used some of these lessons from
microtesting that we did
microtest programming and sorry
microtest writing
over the years and we used that to kind
of inform us and how we could do
microtest programming
and so there are a few programming tasks
that people
could do on a mobile device and we
implemented that experience and we
turned that it turned out that people
actually appreciated the ability to
take their programming tasks or micro
tests outside of the programming
environment and be able to do a few
things on the go and finally there's
also this notion about okay so you are
driving a car which probably we're not
doing a lot these days
but are there certain things that we
could get done in the car without
compromising the car safety
and we found that if you could present
tasks in a very
low cognitive load inducing kind of way
you could get a few things done
but people also try to build context as
you're presenting many of these so you
need to be careful about how you present
the task to the people
in conclusion so the question is that is
micro productivity the solution to
remote core productivity challenges
where switching back and forth is common
resumption of an interrupted task is
challenging because you are often
interrupted at the wrong moment
so one solution could be is that well
try to break your test down more and
more so that the micro tests are
resonating to interruptions
can help with ramp up and ram down from
work and even as i was recording this
presentation which is quite a number of
slides i had to pause and stop
multiple times because there were
interruptions there were like recording
issues
and so breaking it down into those like
smaller chunks actually helped me
uh create this presentation and uh on
that note i would like to end
if you have questions please put them in
the hub channel and
also my email is here and as well as my
research page
thank you very much
all right well thank you so much chomsky
for that great talk
um and this is a reminder we'll be
having an interactive q a with all the
speakers
after after all three talks um but now
i'm going to introduce our next speaker
our next speaker is alex polizzov coming
to us from the grail team
at microsoft research which stands for
grounded reasoning
and interactive learning and alex is
going to speak to us a little bit about
his research
in neurosymbolic ai and program
synthesis
so take it away alex
thank you sean right hello everyone
uh welcome to the talk so as john
mentioned i'm a
senior researcher at the grail group
here at microsoft research
and we work on the intersection of
machine learning
and the programming languages research
deep learning has given us
a wonderful way to understand raw data
in image language or speech domain and
by now
in probably most of the domains out
there and learn distributed
representations of these find patterns
in large noisy data sets however if the
data
is structured like we're working with
knowledge bases or graphs
this is trickier and of course the
hunger for
many many examples of data is still a
big challenge
in the deep learning world on the flip
side we know
how to describe procedural knowledge for
the past few decades
already we've been doing that with
programs
programs are interpretable they provide
an easy way to see if they work and they
can generalize well
however they're very time consuming to
create and acquire extensive prior
knowledge so limited to
high-value tasks and specialists not to
mention that they are not applicable to
many
in all of the settings so we want to
learn to use and create programs
leveraging the advances of machine
learning
and you want to explore their use to
make
many of the tasks that work with
structure more interpretable systematic
and generalizable
an intersection of these two is what
we're calling neurosymbolic ai
the specific approach with which we
approaches is called program synthesis
and some of you may be familiar with
program synthesis
in its most famous application perhaps
flash fill
the feature in microsoft excel that
automatically generates programs for
data transformation from input output
examples
so in this case for instance on the
slide if you want to create a combined
name column
out of these three columns you could
write an excel formula
but that requires non-trivial syntax
learning
instead you could simply provide an
example in this row two
and excel will autocomplete this to
generate a combined name in all the rest
of the columns by learning
a program the desired excel formula for
you behind the scenes
in this case it will actually require a
conditional depending on the presence of
a middle name
so you will need to provide one more
example in order to learn a complex
desired formula
since the last decade of research
program synthesis starting from data
wrangling in excel
has been generalized to a whole
framework of tasks for
input output example driven learning and
has been used in tons of different
applications for
web automation and scraping data from
web pages
for automatic refactoring of code in
visual studio from input output examples
as well as in academia and other
colleagues for automatic visualization
program learning
and many others all of these or most of
these so far
have been examples of symbolic program
synthesis learning
using tools coming from the programming
language literature
in the rest of this talk what i'm going
to show is our exploration and how to
use these tools
as a basis for enabling neurosymbolic ai
how to bring these two worlds together
the neural world of
distributed representations and the
symbolic world of structure
and logic and reasoning they can help
each other
on one hand we can use neural networks
to guide the symbolic search for
programs and we can use their power to
learn from
raw data signals and on the other hand
we can use programs to impose
systematicity
and generalization in the computation
that the neural network performs
and have their reasoning process be
interpretable and executable i'm going
to explore this
in three different applications here so
build order will go over web process
automation
automatically teaching an agent to
perform tasks over web pages
talking about conversation over tables
how to ask questions over a database
translate them into sql programs and
engage in a dialogue over a data source
and ask questions over images and then
it's a logical structure
in visual question answering so let's
see all of these
in order i'll start with web process
automation
uh this is a work that started from our
ai residency program uh
you can see a picture of several of our
ai residents from cambridge here on the
slide this has been a wonderful endeavor
starting from the last three years
so in web based automation what we want
to do
is teaching an agent to perform a task
automatically or web pages like for
instance
sending nlp related news every day at a
certain time
in order to do that what we need to do
today is to show the task step by step
by loading the web page performing
all of the required actions like typing
the search term in the search bar
pressing enter and then actually
following up with email
now in this is a simple example
but instances like this happen in real
life
all the time when you interact with
forms you interact with legacy
applications you collect data from
various web pages and hours and hours
every day i spent on doing this manually
in practice the problem is known as
robotic process automation
here you see an example of a recording
tool microsoft called
uh part of the power app suit and
this is a billion dollar
opinion area so what we want to do
is to learn an example of a task from a
single demonstration
and then generalize that to equivalent
websites
doing the search the same task
importantly
when you're dealing with web pages you
cannot afford to do exploration or
simulators if your task
is to pay your rent every month uh you
can't
quite afford to let your agent explore
your bank interface and try different
programs until it succeeds
you may not have enough funds to succeed
and you really really want the actions
that the agent act performs
to be guaranteed to be consistent with
the demonstration you perform you want
to be able to explore that logic and
verify that it works
now in program synthesis this is a
classic problem known as programming by
demonstrations
where you start with a webpage and the
user
gives you a demonstration of the actions
you want to be performed over that web
page
on the flip side the developer has a
domain specific language or a dsl
of programs in which we would like the
agent's actions to perform so
this can be an extension of css plus
actions over the web page plus some
logic in between
and we'd like the computer to take a
demonstration
and search this language of programs for
one program that is consistent with the
demonstration and
is the desired one in this example let's
just click
one webpage element identified on the
right of another webpage element
the problem with this view is that how
the
user actually arrived at that
demonstration is hidden from us
we don't know the latent reasoning by
which they arrive to the certain action
like clicking
and in fact there is usually hundreds
and thousands of programs in the domain
specific language that are consistent
with that click
but arrive at it with a different logic
and it's very hard to choose between
them
they look very similar to the computer
now
what if in addition to the demonstration
we also provide this explanation a
natural language description
of why and what is being done
by the user so in the this is known as
semantic parsing
in the ai literature and the classic
view of semantic parsing
is that you start with natural language
description you generate a program from
there
and then if you have some other evidence
for instance you know
what is the output of a program if it is
to be evaluated over the web page
you just filter the programs from the
parsing model
until you find the one the most probable
program that also results in the same
demonstration and
in there you cannot by definition
guarantee consistency you have to filter
for it
synthesis can give us this consistency
so the idea that
we are blowing this work is to flip it
and say
let's build a generative model of
natural language explanations
and starting with a web page and a
demonstration
automatically generate a program that is
consistent with it and then ensure
that the programs that we learn are both
consistent with demonstration
and relevant to the natural language
explanation mathematically that means
that we'd like
to maximize both the probability of
consistency
and the probability of relevancy
probability of consistency
is a symbolic process we need to want to
ensure that the program is consistent
with a
web page and a demonstration over that
web page and the probability of
relevancy
is a classic generative inference models
that we know how to optimize in the
semantic parsing view
so the end-to-end view process works
like this
you start with a task description and
conditioned on the task description
you'd like the agent to emit a program
that you later apply to other web pages
in this task
what the user gives us is a pair
of an explanation and a demonstration
front
first we use program synthesis to
generate a set of programs that are
consistent with demonstrations
and then we optimize over that set
to learn a pair of models that align the
program
with the natural language explanation
and then we choose among the consistent
programs the one that is most aligned
thus you get the benefits of both worlds
just based on the fact
that you use the symbolic
representations as a mean to an agent
to realize its logic rather than just
perform these actions
out of the box blindly this has
several key benefits first of all it
strictly outperforms either semantic
parsing or program synthesis
on many tasks it generalizes much better
to different web pages or the same task
just from a single explanation
and a single demonstration on a single
web page
and what's also more interesting it is
competitive with
reinforcement learning based methods
which would actually require exploration
and playing with the browser in order to
get to the same accuracy
over thousands of episodes and
from the way we model the problem we can
get this
uh visualization of how exactly the
words
in the utterance correspond to the
components of the program
so not only we understand the logic by
which the agent operates we understand
how the constituents of that logic align
with what had been said
and we can show it to these okay
so here's another example where you are
going to
flip the qa model a little bit this is
an example of
conversations over data so in
conversations over data
what we want to do is enable question
answering
over databases that in this example we
have an interface of some
uh employees and shops in the
hypothetical company
and we'd like to give a person an
ability to ask questions over this
and explore the stats and analytics
in technical terms this is known as the
cross-domain text-to-sql mapping
specifically what we have is a database
over his particular domain a question
and we'd like to map it to the
corresponding sql program
that realizes this question you could
map it to the answer directly
but again having a sql program in
between
gives interpretability gives you
generalization and allows you to
actually gain more trust with the user
who can expect the program
importantly you need to be able to
generalize to unseen domains
because you don't know on which database
your model will be applied
and it's not guaranteed that you will
have thousands of
programs annotated in that
domain so you need to work well out of
the box this is known as a schema
encoding and linking problem
where for instance let's look at this
example of a question over countries
in order to understand that question and
map it to the program on the right
we need to be able to say okay
life expectancy maps to the life
expectancy column that is easy
the official maps to the is official
common slightly harder but still easy
counter is maps to the country name
column and not to any other column that
happens to have the word country
in it because it's a primary key english
maps to the language column which you
may know if you're starting from a
pretreat language model but you would
not know if this is some domain specific
term
and you need to be able to understand
the structure of the database
in order to generate the join clauses
and the linkage in the program correctly
this is known as a schema encoding and
schema linking
problem schema understanding is
generally the hardest for human data
scientists
as they explore a new data set so no
wonder this is also hard for machines as
well
the way we address it is starting with a
state-of-the-art model
in machine learning the transformer
models but then
noticing the following fact in the
transformer model
which is where how you would up use in
natural language understanding
what you usually do is you have all to
all pairs matching between the set of
inputs in our case the inputs of words
in the question
and columns in the schema however
it is possible to extend this
and introduce additional weights
on the edges between different pairs of
inputs
this has been used couple years past in
order to enable
relative position embeddings in the
transformer model
and we use it in order to enable
arbitrary edge feature encoding
for the same purposes so we call this
module relation of our transformer
and let me explain this in a couple more
details
what relational transformer allows us to
do is to take
arbitrary structure of the problem at
hand and
introduce it into the model encoding
without necessarily biasing the model
just do that just giving it as a signal
so
in graft neural network you would limit
yourself only to the schema structure
in a vanilla transformer you would not
have any structure and let the model
learn it from scratch which is usually
challenging
and rat gives you a soft bias combining
the best of both worlds
in our specific problem setting the
structure that we are interested in
is the database schema foreign relations
correspondence but also the pairing
between
question words column words matches
between the names
and the content and many many other
things this is
after you do this in per training or in
fine tuning depending on the structure
of the task
for us we stay on top of the
leaderboard for all the conversational
semantic parsing tasks by now
and more interestingly we
this kind of model generalizes much
better
there is no gap between the two the dev
setting and the test setting
and there is no need for any target
domain knowledge or
in domain adaptation for a particular
database
we also used it in several different
follow-ups on the same setting
one is you can use the same model for
conversational interaction
where instead of asking a single
question you engage in a dialogue as
humans often do
to ask new questions to clarify previous
ones or to correct mistakes of the model
and you can use the same to learn these
corrections of mistakes
and translate your feedback that someone
might give you
about a wrongly emitted program into a
diff between the wrong limited program
and the one that should have been
emitted when applying the same method
there
fixes about half of the errors that even
our
model however good it is often makes
okay the final part of the talk i want
to
touch a little bit about visual question
answering also a residency project
so what we saw in the past two previous
ones was
a program a symbolic program being used
as a vehicle to enable question
answering tasks typical ai question
answering tasks
in here we will have similar structure
but it will be embedded in the network
continuously
so to form a few words visual question
answering
all starts with an image and a question
and asks a vqa model to answer that
question
as shown here on the slide and that
requires us to combine
two different problems the perception
problem
understanding what actually is happening
in the image and which objects are
relations are present there
and the reasoning problem parsing the
question into some logic
and executing that logic in order to
answer the question
the two together are form the
foundations of visual question answering
and neither pure logical reasoning
nor purely neural perception can
accomplish the task alone the perception
is usually noisy and uncertain
and thus you cannot rely on it hundred
percent
in order to logically interpret what the
question
asks you and execute that so for
instance
if your perception model misidentified
this husky
as a wolf then even if you
interpret the question perfectly you
would not be unable to answer it
correctly
yet the phrasing of the question or the
visual context of the image
should be able to do that
on the flip side purely neural reasoning
is unsystematic
so and there have been lots and lots of
papers
that show evidence of our
vqa models not being sufficiently
grounded in their
reasoning capabilities this is an
example of just a recent cvpr paper
that shows if you ask the same model two
similar questions about the same image
their answers
can have nothing to do with each other
what we suggest is to actually
incorporate
logical reasoning into the neural model
as an intermediate block
in order to ensure that the reasoning is
both systematic
and properly takes into account the
distributed nature of perception we
start with a
logical representation but we will make
it continuous
so the discrete logical representation
is a description of a scene
as a set of variables corresponding
objects and relations between them
and this is an example on the right that
shows you how you can describe the whole
scene in this entire scene graph
as a single formula this formula
can be interpreted as a question can be
interpreted as a statement
and you can perform inference over this
formula
in order to get the either the logical
value of it
depending on which values you assign to
the variables or
if you relax at continuously the
probabilities
of the different statements about the
same world
and that is what we do in this paper
what we show is that if you start with a
question
on uk you can map it to
an implementation of a formula that can
be relaxed
as a neural network continuously and
once you have that neural network that
continuously
implements the logic of the question you
can train
end to end the perception and reasoning
systems
using that logical representation as
your objective
so how it looks like is this where
first you map the natural language
description to a program
in this case the program is the logical
formula and this is done by semantic
parser similar to
the kind that i showed previously on the
flip side
you use the visual perception models in
order to
featurize the image and map into a set
of objects and relations with
probabilities associated over them
and then the relaxed continuous
interpretation of this formula
acts as a second half of your question
answering
model where the individual models
look at the probabilities of the objects
and relations in the image and perform
steps of reasoning corresponding to the
operations in the formula
like in this example that would be first
step of
filtering objects that
correspond to as predicate men and then
filtering object and then relating from
these objects
to the other set of objects based on the
left
geometric relation all of this can be
trained
end-to-end once you have a data set of
questions and answers
and a certain number of intermediate
programs
so to conclude the
joint lessons from these and many other
projects
that uh we learned and we want to in one
bond
the audience is that you can use
programs programmatic representations
logical representations
not just as a symbolic tool in order to
accomplish tasks that have traditionally
been discretely symbolic
but also as intermediate representations
in neurosymbolic ai tasks such as
question answering
be it or tables or images or web pages
or other kinds of context once you do
that in the right way
you can improve systematicity and the
out-of-domain generalization of your
question answering
because programs are compositional just
like language is compositional
and you can take the same program once
it's generated
and apply to other tasks that are
similar in spirit but different in
details
programs can be relaxed into
interpretable program-like
models like the question answering
models of the vqa task that i showed
and the multimodality of
the language and vision and other kinds
of data that
deep learning has enabled us to work
with can be applied to program synthesis
here
as well thank you for listening
i'm happy to answer your questions later
in the q a
that is all
great thank you alex
so for our for our third talk uh and our
final talk of the session
um i would like to introduce robert sim
robert is from the the ktx group at msr
which stands for knowledge technologies
and intelligent experiences
um he does a lot of great work on
privacy preserving
machine learning um and today he's going
to talk to us a little bit about privacy
preservation
and natural language applications should
take it away robert
uh hi my name is robert sim i'm a
principal applied science
manager in msr my team explores problems
in
natural language understanding and
privacy applications of training models
using natural language
so why don't we just jump right in
you've probably seen this cartoon before
it's a kind of simplistic view of what's
in fact of
relatively large uh attack surface for
natural language models
um if we think about uh data that's
transformed into
a model and hosted in the cloud or on
device
they're made for attackers to
probe the model in the gray box fashion
or black boxed action
in order to either extract training
examples
or determine membership in the training
set
in addition there could be the
possibility that some rogue insider
probes model and has complete access to
the model
but we also have risks of legitimate
users and
uh internal data scientists accidentally
exposing
uh customer content just by probing the
model directly
during normal usage
so this presents some interesting
challenges for us of how we
safely train these models and deploy
them
the current state of the art for
privacy in this space is differential
privacy
um but both differential privacy and
many other mitigations you when we apply
them it usually implies some kind of
utility loss
and in addition the guarantees that
are provided by differential privacy uh
focus on the worst case
possible guarantees um and these
actually may be much more conservative
than attacker's actual capabilities
um so that leaves us some space where we
feel that there's there's room to
maneuver and
explore okay what what sorts of
mitigations could we develop
and what sorts of analysis can we do to
understand the gap between a practical
attack and
um and the worst case guarantees
provided by differential privacy
um there are also some other um
aspects of differential privacy where
there's more work to be done one one is
it's
generally assumed that um the the
examples that we're protecting
are independently distributed but in
fact especially
if we're training uh language models for
some user base
such as an enterprise their their
emails and and written text may be
highly correlated
so how do we account for this
correlation in the data
um there's actually a wide range of
privacy research happening at microsoft
right now it's actually a
very exciting space to be working in i'm
really just going to focus on
areas related to natural language
generation
model assessment and and
uh mitigations that may not necessarily
be
purely differentially private um in some
cases will leverage
concepts from differential privacy but
um
in other cases we'll we'll try sort of
parallel mitigation
methods uh so if we're going to
train and deploy a model whether it's
with differential privacy or any other
mitigation first we need to understand
what the privacy risks are and what his
privacy
loss is one approach is to just
take the epsilon from a differentially
private process and say okay the privacy
loss or the privacy budget is this
a much but there are some challenges
with this approach
for starters is a worst case estimate
and it could hide some issues with
underlying issues of fairness in the
data that uh
that maybe some users are better
protected than others
um it also assumes that that our
implementation is bug-free if we
if we train using some parameter epsilon
uh then we really have to trust that the
implementation is correct
to conclude that the epsilon is is for
real and
and so that makes this um this whole
process a little bit difficult to verify
and finally we don't really have a good
way to compare with other
non-differentially private mitigations
so we've been taking a more practical
attack thinking about
approach thinking about how um uh
real world attacks work and and
assessing a model's
vulnerability or resilience to um to
those attacks
uh one really important place to start
is by assessing privacy risks in the
training data itself so you can imagine
uh just measuring say mutual information
between
the training content and the user ids
associated with that content
this may give you a measure of the the
general uniqueness of
each record in the system and and um
how uh on average users might be exposed
just by releasing the content on its own
um uh in addition once we train a model
we can think about
assessing the model's susceptibility to
various attacks so we can look at
its propensity for memorization uh
we could apply very kind of naive script
kitty attacks the tab attacker beam and
beam search attack where we're just
basically exercising the model as if it
would normally be exercised and and
measuring how often training examples
are generated
and then finally we can apply more
sophisticated attacks like membership
inference and and
understand what's the likelihood that
an attacker could determine a particular
user's data was used in the
in the process there are other
approaches there's some interesting work
on
estimating epsilon after the model has
been trained and
yeah that's an area that's interesting
to us uh we haven't explored it in any
great detail yet
and so so given an assessment approach
uh the next question is
how can we apply it in uh and and
develop new mitigations
uh for privacy and one area that our
intern
fatima mirskala explored this summer is
how can we build privacy into the um
optimization and machinery of machine
learning
so a high level what like why would we
want to even do that
um for starters uh we may be able to
improve the average case privacy
so do better than
than say um
we get from differential privacy uh on
average across users
and this may uh improve questions of
fairness especially for underrepresented
groups in the data
um it also enables us to directly
quantify the privacy utility trade-off
and
in fact we can tune for privacy versus
utility more
more easily um and
and then finally we can also um tie the
privacy loss
and the the whole machine learning loss
to any sensitive attributes in the
in the data so uh we could basically aim
to regularize away
any features that might be linked to
sensitive attributes in the training set
um and i guess one more thing to mention
is that
the differentially private uh
training algorithms like uh dpsgd today
are still quite expensive to run there's
um quite a bit of effort to improve
their efficiency but they're still quite
a bit slower than
than off-the-shelf machine learning so
if we can
squeeze out any performance improvements
that's a huge benefit especially for
very very large models
so two questions how do we define the
the network privacy
loss and then how will we assess our
model once it's trained
uh we came up with two particular
mitigations
the first is kind of a standard uh
machine learning model that language
model where we take the
the hidden states as their output and
feed them
through a discriminator so this will
look a lot like
uh again if you've seen uh adversarial
networks before and we use an
adversarial setup to train the
discriminator to try to recognize
the which user contributed the
input training examples and
um and in the adversarial setup the
discriminator will
be driven to produce a uniform
distribution so
we're basically trying to smooth away
any identifying features in the hidden
states
uh so such that the discriminator
struggles to identify the source
of the input example um and then the
second
mitigation that we tried uh was a
declustering method and this is
also a smoothing approach where we train
the language model normally
but we provide um in addition to the the
the main training batch we provide an
auxiliary batch
and these examples may come from the
same user from different users
and with the regularization term that we
apply
basically measures the l2 distance
between
pairs pairwise correspondences in the
training and auxiliary batch and if the
two users
in those two batches match um then we
try to push the examples further away so
we try to maximize this distance
but if the two users are different in
the batches then
we try to move the examples closer
together and this has the effect of
basically distributing
um examples through the embedding space
in the
in the hidden states um more evenly
throughout the space without allowing
them to cluster
on a particular user
and this in fact has a quite nice impact
on the
privacy results uh so when we
evaluate um uh the quality of the models
that we generated
uh we applied several metrics i'm just
gonna share two uh
one is the exposure metric uh from the
secret share paper and
the this metric injects synthetic
canaries
into the training data at certain
repetitions so we repeated the number of
canaries
up to 10 times and then 10 20 30 40 and
50 times so each individual canary
may be repeated up to 50 times and then
we measured
exposure which is really the measure of
how easily the canary can be
extracted from the model at
inference time and the blue line here is
a the differentially private solution
um and then our two mitigations are
these two lines down below so as the
as the number of repetitions of
synthetic can areas in the data
increases we notice this increase in
exposure and differentially private
result that doesn't happen in the um
using our mitigations and of course
these these three approaches do much
better than the
um the unmitigated model unfortunately
they also do much better than
a mixed model that seems like this
experiment just
by mixing our two mitigations didn't
work as well
the other measurement that we took
against these models was to compare
the um the utility loss
of the our solutions for different
groups of users in particular
we looked at kind of the best performing
and worst performing users
in the um in the model and and you'll
see that we have this disproportionate
uh loss of perplexity or increase in
perplexity um for the worst performing
users
in the in the model um and all of these
are
all of these models are trained to
roughly the same perplexity so
there's a subgroup in here that's
disproportionately impacted
in comparison uh to the differentially
private approach
um our mitigations showed much
lower um perplexity loss
okay um so that that project was looking
at
questions of how how can we provide kind
of alternative mitigations to
differential privacy
um now i want to think about alternative
formulations of
privacy while taking advantage of all
the mechanisms that differential privacy
provides us with so in the enterprise
if we think about the the structure of
the enterprise
um really the the question for us
becomes one of
uh protecting confidentiality of
information and correspondence versus
protecting the privacy of individuals
and i'll explain a little bit what i
mean by this
if we think about some
organization where we have the ceo alice
and the cfo bob
and then uh you know all of the
employees in the organization
but some subset of those employees
working on some secret project x that is
in fact secret even to the rest of the
organization
uh and suppose we have a goal to train a
language model
for use in this enterprise and in
particular this is not a model for
like public consumption it's just for
use in this business right and so
it's perfectly fine to encode um
business knowledge
that's specialized to this business um
but at the same time we want to
protect things like the confidential
discussions between alice and bob
and the confidential conversations about
project
x so if we think about this in a
conventional privacy sense
um normally in a differentially private
setup we would
train the model to be invariant to say
alice alice's presence or absence in the
data or bob's presence or absence or any
employees
um but from a confidentiality
perspective we'd rather train the model
to be
invariant to the absence or presence of
conversations that take place
between pairs of users so if they have
some confidential or highly sensitive
conversation
the model should not really be very
different
um regardless of whether or not the
conversation happened
uh likewise we want to protect the model
against the
uh or to to be invariant um to the
presence or absence of some project x
excuse me and and finally though um we
have this other constraint which is
really the within the enterprise if
alice or bob or anyone else sends a
message to all the employees
that particular piece of information is
not necessarily private doesn't need to
be protected it's public to the
organization
uh and so we we want to think about
models that account for this fact that
that some of the information in the in
the enterprise is public
um so the approach we took about this um
which is really a kind of a simplified
view of the
language modeling task is to look at
engram extraction
um you can think about this in terms of
say you want to extract some set of
frequent phrases from a corpus or even
identify
um a language model vocabulary in a
different really private way
those are two good examples of where
engram extraction approaches would work
well
the state of the art today is probably
differentially private set union which
is developed by our algorithms group
um and but this approach doesn't really
think about who's talking to who
it's just treating individual users as
the entities that need to be privatized
so um so the way we've set this up
is we take the social network of the
organization
and we frame the problem as one of an
edge labeling task
or or an edge label counting task where
first we label all the edges positive or
negative depending on whether or not a
particular
token or a topic or engram was discussed
between
users a and b um and then we try to
identify okay what's the set of
positive labels that are valid to
extract from the
graph uh in a private privacy preserving
way
and the way we frame this is is using uh
edge level privacy rather than node
level privacy so
trying to extract engrams such that
we're invariant to
the absence or presence of an edge in
the graph
as opposed to in the case of like
protecting against
alice leaving the organization we'd be
protecting against many edges leaving
the graph
at the same time we will also want to
consider the
likelihood that when alice talks to bob
about some topic is it's probable that
sometimes she's also discussing the same
topic with um with her neighbors and bob
is likewise discussing with his
neighbors
this is a little bit and maybe subtly
different from group privacy where we
assume
everyone talks about the topic um and we
have 100 correlation between all the
edges
uh this is kind of a catastrophic
challenge for differential privacy
because we
have to add noise that's commensurate
with the group size
whereas in the in the correlated case
maybe we don't need to add quite as much
noise i'm not going to go into the
details of our solution
uh just for the lack of time but we're
relying on our approach based on puffer
fish privacy
and then this concept of the washer
stein distance which
studies the the effect of um
the the total shift in the probability
distribution
of our output measure which in our case
would be the
count of positively labeled edges um
so the uh consequence of flipping an
edge
on a um uh
on a particular edge in the graph sorry
flipping the label in a particular edge
in the graph
um we have some results that we ran on
avocado is a relatively small data set
so it's
challenging to run differentially
private algorithms on it only has 393
nodes and about 21 000 edges
largest neighborhood is reasonably large
it has 1800 edges adjacent to it
and uh using just basic edge level
privacy we get about 25 000
engrams extracted this is far better
than the standard node level privacy
kind of the default approach which would
only yield 91 algorithms and
then in our examination of how
correlation could play a role
um we were able to extract about 230
engrams compared to group privacy which
would yield only 40.
and this w here is really the parameter
that's estimating the
amount of correlation or or the
sensitivity of the algorithm
okay so that's about um
all i have to share on this particular
topic we're still still writing this
particular work up but there's still
some important questions to answer like
how do we scale to very very large
graphs
um and then how do we translate this
problem which was kind of an edge
labeling problem into a model training
one
and uh ultimately we want to build a
language model that accounts for these
correlations
and its edge-based approach to
privacy so just to wrap up um
yeah i just want to underscore i think
this is a really exciting time for
privacy research at microsoft
it's one of our core
value propositions to our customers we
take it very very
seriously and at the same time we
understand
that there's a lot of value
in using their data to provide them with
value and especially our business
customers you know there's a lot of
business insights they could leverage
from their enterprise data so uh
it's really important to us that we
understand where the privacy risks
when we train models and and how can we
pass on
that understanding and provide our
customers with the tools they need
so that they can unlock value as well
lots of interesting open questions in
this space how can we apply federated
learning and
privacy in that space how could we
take advantage of synthetic generate
data generators
use that to enhance our models without
infringing in on anyone's privacy
how can we personalize models at scale
and
um ultimately ultimately how can we
just improve the the overall privacy
utility trade-off
so we'll stop there and we'll take
questions thank you
okay great well thank you for that talk
robert um
so before we get into the q a with the
the panel of speakers we're just going
to take a a
quick five minute break um give everyone
a chance to
to go get a glass of water stretch your
legs
and then we'll be back here in five
minutes uh first
for some q a and see you back here
thanks
all right uh welcome back everyone um so
now we're going to have the uh q a panel
with the speakers so i'm here with
tromsy alex and robert um thank you all
for for your great talks
and uh for being with us for this q a um
i'm going to start with shromsi um and
if there were a few questions that kind
of came in the chat that
i think touched on some similar topics
and touched on
kind of a question i had and probably a
question that you've gotten many times
with this work on microtasks
um but i mean it's interesting it came
up in in one of our breakup groups
earlier today
the the concept of flow and the concept
of
being in like a state of deep focus and
attention
and i'm wondering what your thoughts are
on that versus
micro tasking and especially kind of the
timing of when micro tasks are
suggested to users um because it seems
like that's a real dichotomy there like
i probably don't want to be
i'm not in a micro test mode when i'm
kind of deeply focused on something
but when i'm feeling more fragmented or
i'm on the go that's a great time to be
suggesting you microtasks
so is there any work on kind of getting
that timing right or sort of
distinguishing those two states or how
do you think about that
yeah i think that that's actually a
great question um
and the way that we think about
microtask is it's a complement to your
focused work or when you're in flow
and in some sense microtasks can
actually help you with flow which might
seem a bit counter-intuitive
because say you are in flow but there is
something that's bugging you
and you know that well if i don't make
if i don't address this now
i'm gonna lose it but as soon as you
switch to address that task and that's
kind of like you're opening up this
this black hole of distraction so one
way of thinking about is that well maybe
you
defer that as a microtask and so we we
we have some ways of doing that and so
there
there's some tools that are being
released also
in microsoft word that will help you
kind of defer these thoughts as micro
tests so you could imagine that well
i want to be an example is i'm writing a
paper i'm in flow
and i need to add in a citation i can
just typically what we do is that we add
in an inline note and so that is
essentially a micro task so that's one
way
uh the other one is that well again it's
a complement to your focus work
and so when you have a minute uh you
have
i mean you're waiting for a meeting to
start
as an alternative to playing games so
you could
look at some of your micro tests now
there's also the flip side is that you
don't want to fill up
all your micro moments with just work
and so i think that that's something
that we have to be really careful about
is that we want microtest to be
something that helps people
feel happy and satisfied and productive
as well as helping them
feel that they are not getting
overworked or burnt out
uh it might be a way for you to feel
that well i need to get this done
quickly
it's out of my mind i'm done i can now
focus on whatever i'm supposed to be
focusing on or i can be present in my
other experiences
so that's the way that we hope that
microtasks will be used
uh what happens in practice where that's
yet to be seen
great great thanks
um i had a question for alex
so so i was really taken by like some of
the stuff you were talking about
especially in
the the first project you were talking
about this whole approach
this kind of generate and filter
approach to program synthesis of
kind of generating a lot of possible
matching programs by observing some
behavior
um and then using the natural language
explanations to kind of filter down to
select the the correct one so i
have a couple of questions along those
lines first of all i'm curious like
does did the natural language
explanations help
modify the program ever or fill in slots
or things like that or
is it more kind of purely selecting from
from a set
of programs um and then i'm also just
curious about
how how that approach might apply to
other domains where i've seen like
programming by demonstration especially
in robotics
where i'm like demonstrating some robot
motions
either just through acting things out
with my body or moving the robot
um but i wonder if there's any work on
i'm also doing that where i can explain
verbally what i'm doing to help doing
that
program yeah yeah so
regarding the natural language uh in
this particular
work the natural language is a means to
explain
the latent logic of the agent the
program
rather than change modified you could
use it as a modality for modification
or prefer their interaction and
conversation about the task
as we do in say database question
answering with a show later
but we just don't do it in this
particular case but it's possible
it is not that natural to the modality
of this particular task where you want
to
provide a demonstration and explain the
logic and that is
what how the intent is communicated
both via the demonstration and the
aligned text
interestingly you do want the align text
because
it mentions entities that are uh
hidden from just from the nature of the
program it mentions things like
intermediate states of the program
clicking on
something next to another button where
the another button
was selected by a different logic so
there is
no easy way to recover that without just
searching over the programs and the
natural language gives you the grounding
that helps you to
explain how to arrive at it
regarding the other applications so
the robotics one is actually quite
relevant there is
plenty of work generally in the
literature about programming by
demonstration
uh there is a big difference between a
single demonstration
that can be translated into a trace of
actions the sequence
and a program that includes logic such
as
conditionals as where you need to do
something in one case and something else
in another any individual demonstration
is going to only walk you through one
situation the one that you saw in this
case
similarly with loops when you need to
perform a particular action
up to a certain condition and any
individual demonstration is going to
only demonstrate an unrolling of this
loop
a few individual iterations of it so
generalizing from demonstrations to
programs is the key to ask in this uh
kind of settings we actually have an
ongoing line of work
where we try to use it as a means to
guide an embodied agent in a virtual
environment
where imagine a game-like environment
where you have an agent navigating a
house and performing household tasks
like heating up food or washing dishes
or
any other things and if you just
guide the agent with natural language
alone and you let them
uh perform the action step by step
the accuracy is quite low it is
difficult to generalize
natural language high-level instructions
into sequences of steps that need to
generalize from one room to another
but it is my possible potentially
if you assume this more programmatic
representation
now this is ongoing work so i don't want
to talk too much about this but the
short answer is
yes this kind of approach is applicable
to
in principle most settings
when you're trying to perform a complex
compositional task
that needs to be represented as some
kind of program these are logic
parts and the actionable parts
yeah like it because it does seem like
it would be very applicable
in ways that i haven't seen done so much
before but where
i'm still thinking about where like i'm
trying to teach the robot to pick up
some objects in the environment but
maybe i'm trying to teach you two things
at once like
it's my manufacturing robot and i'm not
only just showing you how to pick up
cubes but i also want to convey that it
should pick up all the blue cubes
yes i want to convey some program that
it can follow
not just to pick up this one object but
to then kind of continue uh
applying that to the rest of its domain
yeah and you need to
the the challenge is also that you are
mixing up the maturities and perception
and the reasoning of the task the
program itself
and if the reasoning is somehow
decoupled in their underlying
representations that makes the teaching
easier yes yes
thank you um robert there was a question
for you
that came into the chat um and it's
about
uh interpretability so so the question
is
from from tom asking about it seems that
the lack of interpretability is a major
obstacle to having users
sort of trust the privacy of current ai
so we're wondering how do you view that
issue uh are there ways to build trust
even if these models are black boxes as
they usually are
or do we need to solve interpretability
first
to really kind of convey any kind of
ability to trust that privacy is being
respected
yeah thank you thanks sean yeah that's a
really important question
um i think maybe there are a couple
parts to it
the first is really thinking about
interpretability
as a diagnostic tool
how can we take advantage of
interpretability so
we understand why the model did what it
did and
and what went wrong so in cases where
uh model produces a bad text completion
or recommendation
or or classification we
we kind of have all the features at hand
that can tell us okay you know is this
is this a problem in the model or is
this a problem with the um
even with our training data uh
so that's really about our ability to
trust the models that we ship
um the the other question uh of
how we can leverage interpretability to
uh build
trust in users um i think fundamentally
we believe that transparency is super
important uh
really the open question has more to do
with what the ux should look like and
and how do we
um uh under what circumstances do we
kind of you know reveal what happened
behind the curtain that that led to a
particular
response from the model um and
you know in in scenarios like text
completion that's a little bit tricky
because
it's not like in line we're going to be
able to provide a
compelling reason or even you know
interfere with the user's flow to tell
them why we're delivering this
particular
uh suggestion um and
yeah i think you know there's some
really interesting open questions there
i'm not an expert in interpretability
itself i would probably defer to other
folks
in in our organization who could give a
more
you know nuanced answer than i can but i
definitely see
has an important role to play great
great thanks um well that brings us
uh basically to the end of our session
it's just about 3 30.
uh so i once again want to thank our
speakers chomsky alex robert thank you
so much for being here thank you for
your great talks
thank you sean thank you chanfer and
thanks everyone for watching
thank you everyone okay so like i said
that's
that's about 3 30. um we're gonna wrap
up the event
uh daniel did you want to say a few
words
in closing sure yeah we just wanted to
say
uh thank you so much for joining us it
really is one of the
great pleasures of working at msr that
we were able to interact with
such talented and motivated researchers
phd students postdocs
so thank you for sharing your work with
us thank you for letting us
share our work with you um and spending
these two days
um it's it's been a
really great event from my my
perspective and
i would also like to say thank you to
the people behind the scenes sarah
matt ryan um too
uh jen for all your work putting this
together
for um hosting uh making sure everything
flowed
uh from one point to another answering
all our questions
uh it's uh obviously wouldn't have been
possible without you so
very grateful for that and i'll pass
back to you sean for the final words
yeah so thanks like i'll just reiterate
this was a great uh
two days i i hope you all had a lot of
fun and i hope you got to meet some
new people um you know it's a it's a
challenging event to try to transform
into being all virtual
um but i hope that um you got a lot out
of it
the talks the fireside chats the the
interactive breakout stuff
the poster sessions um i hope you guys
had a good experience um and i do want
to say that
you shouldn't view this endpoint as like
the end of you know your last
opportunity to speak with anyone here
like
you should totally feel free um and
encouraged to
keep reaching out to us keep reaching
out to if there are other researchers
that you didn't get a chance to interact
with over the last two days
um you should feel absolutely empowered
to
still email them and reach out to them
because we're all
super excited and would be more than
happy to to talk to every one of you
um so with that uh i'll wrap it up here
and just say thanks again for coming
bye everyone